well blights miss congratulations you're
moving on to the third and final round
of our competition you guys are gonna
have four days to build yet another
weapon from the mind of doug marcaido
bladesmiths
i'm always interested in raising the bar
and supersizing the challenge
so for this final round i want you to
build this
look at that a super-sized cortada sword
the cortadon was inspired by the
gennunting knife this is inspired by a
gnunting sword it's fast it's light it's
double edged great for thrusting and
cutting and it definitely
will kill gentlemen you will have four
days of your home forges to bring back a
blade that is worth at least ten
thousand dollars gentlemen good luck
we'll see in four days good luck buddy
good luck to you
i'm trinity trout i'm 43 from pueblo
colorado and i'm a part-time bladesmith
i used to watch a lot of medieval movies
when i was a kid really got into the
swords and the knives and i started
making blades when i was about 16. i'm
excited to be here looking forward to
the challenge
it's looking good so far biggest
challenge is to make sure that they get
good clean bevels ground into the sword
that bevel jib really helps keep things
nice and straight and on a blade like
this we have real pronounced clean
bevels that are expected as part of the
parameters
there we go
i've got a good medium pitch edge on the
blade it's sharp at the same time but
durable
let's see what happens
so i've got all my major bevels ground
in and i'll be working on the other
components of the blade
i need to finalize the handle profile
get it all sanded up nice and smooth and
then assembly it's going to be tight but
we're going to get done
getting ready to pour silver onto the
handle
kind of made a silver end cap and a
silver collar
and that really set off the handle i had
all these components started but nothing
finished today so it all came together
at the last minute i wish i had one more
hour it would have been a lot better to
really make that handle the way i wanted
it to but it just didn't work out what
the hell just beat the hell out of it
my name is jason coy i'm 41 years old my
wife and i started watching fortune fire
and it kind of reminded me of wanting to
make knives as a kid that i'd forgotten
and so i decided to give it a shot
i'm going to do a rough grind on it and
then i'm going to quench it
so i have this blade ready for quinch
it's nerve-wracking i'm ready to do it
about to become a blade
i need to find out if i actually have a
good blade here
let that soak then i'll quench during
the quinch the blade could bend it could
warp it could break ready hopefully it
goes well
she's straight
we got a blade
i like it
the quinch quit great i couldn't be
happier i have a straight blade it's
hardened it's ready to go
looks good
i'm ready to get this s guard shaped i'm
going to start at the top here and start
bending it over and checking how it
looks and keep going until i'm happy
with it that's cool
so i have everything uh dry fitted here
it's all put together looking good i'm
really happy with how this is coming
together on the fit and finish feels
good in my hand i'm gonna get an edge on
this thing we've got a little bit of
time left here and i'm getting this
blade nice and sharp i want to test it
on some wood just to make sure it's a
high quality blade
the blade performed great edge held up
no damage i know trinity is going to
bring it so i know it's going to be
close all done man
basements welcome to the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do i'm going to
deliver some lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy jason you're up first
are you ready for this yes sir all right
let's do this
it's gonna be a tough test hopefully it
cuts well
all right jason talk about your super
size cortada sword here
it cuts deep when i'm slashing with it
the double edge pierces nicely cuts on
the way out and it is fun to wield
overall sir this cortada sword
it will kill a little whoa i'm just so
excited about this man
all right trinity are you ready sir kill
it oh yes i will
all right trains let's talk about your
super-sized cortada sword here first up
the design you have cuts deep into this
ballistic zombie the double edge cuts on
the way out that damascus pattern really
shows your handle it's got a belly there
it's got the flare that i want overall
sir your kurtara
it will kill very nice all right
gentlemen that was awesome not to share
the fun
dave
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test our bamboo pole chop
remember this test is not about what
your super-sized cortadas do to the
bamboo but what that bamboo mite due to
your super-sized cortadas jason you're
up first you ready yes sir okay
[Music]
all right jason first off your handle is
absolutely perfect for my hand your
blade it's as straight as when i started
everything's right and tight and edge no
damage at all good job thanks sir
trinity your turn to play you ready
let's do it sir cool
[Music]
all right trinity first off blade's
still straight
everything's still right and tight
your edge didn't take any damage at all
your handle construction is really
smooth but one of the times that i hit
that blade
it did a little bit of a rotating in my
hand
but everything's held up beautifully
nice and done thank you sir all right
gentlemen i'll give you a dug
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpness test of charging dummy slice
i'm gonna take your weapons and try to
slice across these dummies and what
they're wearing jason you're up first
you ready yes sir let's do this
all right jason let's talk about your
weapon here your edges are very sharp
the slices are clean you cut the ties in
half overall sir your cortada it will
cut thanks sir all right trinity your
turns are you ready let's do it let's do
this
i'm still not out of the woods my edge
still looks like it's sharp but it'll be
difficult to slice the clothing
all right trinity let's talk about your
edge here you have a more obtuse grind
on this edge compared to the other one
but it does cut some of the pieces over
here and overall sir
it will cut
you have fun
absolutely
well done guys
well blaise miss i want to say
congratulations both of you guys i
haven't seen blades this beautiful
perform as well as yours did in a long
time so you both have a ton to be proud
of
but in this competition only one of you
is leaving here with the title of
fortune fire champion and a check for
ten thousand dollars the judges have
deliberated and they made their decision
today's fortune fire champion is
jason congratulations man now trinity
you fought extremely hard but
unfortunately your blade did not come
out on top and doug's gonna tell you why
trinity first stop the craftsmanship on
your blade is just amazing but when it
came down to the finer details your edge
though sharp just isn't as sharp as
jason's also the handle is a little bit
on the larger side and requires some
adjustments when wielding it i
understood
well trinity it's been an honor to watch
you work you are clearly an extremely
talented smith and honestly in almost
any other competition you'd be going
home with the win
but the competition was extremely fierce
this time and at this point i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
forge floor roger that
i felt like i did well but i would have
spent a little bit more time on the edge
obviously
the hardest part was the time management
for sure i didn't win today but it was a
great experience overall and i'm happy
for it
well jason congratulations that means
you are the fortune fire champion and
you just got yourself a check for ten
thousand dollars congratulations thank
you thank you this is one fortune fire
i knew it was gonna be neck and neck and
i knew trinity was gonna bring an
awesome blade and he did
it's my wife's birthday today happy
birthday love you
my name is jason coy i'm the fortune
fire champion word of god
you